uh there's a very interesting segment
from msnbc that i want to look at with
you where a republican strategist went
on and said
trump's influence trump's power in the
republican party is rapidly diminishing
as evidenced by his smaller and smaller
rally crowds you thought i was going to
say some trump's smaller and so smaller
something else no i'm talking about his
rally crowds of course uh this is a
really interesting segment and there's
actually a very interesting political
question here um donald trump has long
equated crowd size with success even
bragging about the size of the january 6
riot mob republican strategist susan del
percio said trump is now falling short
by that measure as his rally crowds
decrease in size now one important thing
is you might say but david trump hasn't
conceded that his rally crowds are
diminishing in size i know we covered a
recent trump rally
and trump said there were 87 000 people
in the audience there were five to seven
thousand people in the audience trump
recently did an event where you can
publicly look up the capacity of the
venue it was 5500 and trump said there
were tens of thousands of people there
trump's not telling you the truth about
the crowd size but there's a good
question here given that the crowds have
been diminishing is that actually
evidence that trump's influence in the
party is diminishing let's listen to
susan del percio on msnbc i want to ask
you about congressman madison cawthord
how do you interpret that warm welcome
he got is he the future of the gop
absolutely not he is the future of
donald trump and his shrinking base and
that's what you saw there a very
shrinking base i'm not saying that the
republican party is going to come out of
donald trump two for even six years but
even this congress member is being
shunned by members of his own party
donald trump yes he can bring out those
people but those crowds are getting
smaller
and people aren't buying into it mostly
because democrat and republicans excuse
me want to move on they don't want to
talk about the big lie the people of
this country don't want to hear about it
anymore they're done with donald trump
and his lies
except for a small group that we see
there i don't know that that's true
i don't know that that's true
it is clear
that trump's power
may be diminishing and the 2022 midterms
are going to be a big factor in helping
us figure that out
it's not really clear to me that by any
significant margin trump's power in the
republican party is diminishing and i
think it's really important to remember
the 2020 election
if you looked at the democratic primary
before joe biden won it
and you just said let me pick some ways
to determine enthusiasm
you would have seen that joe biden
wasn't having big rally crowds now i
don't know that he was trying because of
the pandemic and things that were going
on at the time but if you took a look at
the rally crowds and then you looked on
reddit and twitter you would have said
oh wow bernie's going to run away with
this thing biden has no chance and it
wasn't reflective of what was going on
with the average democratic voter in so
many different states around the country
and people get mad at me when i say this
i'm not telling you this because it was
the way i would have liked it to be i'm
telling you this because it was the way
it was
joe biden's support was dramatically
understated and bernie support was
dramatically overstated similarly
trump had far bigger crowds than biden
throughout the throughout the campaign a
lot of it was biden wasn't trying to do
big events because of the pandemic but
if you go by rally crowd i think you're
going to end up confused there are lots
of people who just don't see politicians
as cult leaders essentially
they don't really care about going to a
rally i don't care about political
rallies you know
i'm not looking to put myself in
situations where i've got to line up for
four hours outside
uh and then use these feted sani cans
for hours while i'm waiting for to i
i'll just watch it at home i don't need
to go and so i don't really know that we
can make too much of the rally crowds a
few things we can look at are polls if
you look at recent republican primary
polls from the last couple of months you
see that in nevada donald trump is still
easily winning if you these are 2024
polls in massachusetts among republicans
donald trump is easily winning in
minnesota trump is winning uh actually
no i'm sorry in minnesota trump is not
winning uh but in most states trump is
either basically tied for first or
easily in first place so i just don't
think we have the evidence at this point
that trump's power in the party is
diminishing again looking at the
predict.org numbers these are the
betting numbers trump is still
i don't want to say running away with it
but
39 cents of every dollar being bet are
trump will be the nominee 29 cents are
going to desantis so that is close that
is close compared to what it was but
trump is still in the lead my hope is
that it's an extraordinarily ugly
divisive and destructive 2024 primary
but to even get to that we've got to get
past the midterms we'll have all of
these stories on our instagram you can
find us there
at david pakman show
one of our sponsors today is the daily
upside a free business and finance
newsletter that i've been hooked on
lately the daily upside was founded by a
team of investment bankers journalists
and scholars for the sole purpose of
providing actionable insights to make
you a more well-rounded investor
every weekday before the markets open
the daily upside delivers interesting
and engaging stories so i get context on
what's happening with that day's
financial news the content is really
witty it's useful it's digestible i
really feel like it's always worth my
time especially because it's just a
quick five minute read and once a week
they'll do a deep dive newsletter
unpacking more complex business trends
still in a way that's easy to understand
but it makes you meaningfully enriched
on these topics there's a reason why 250
000 people have already subscribed to
the daily upside and start every morning
with it and again it's totally free
go to davidpakman.com
upside the link is underneath the video